[Music]
you
one of the most poignant and confusing
moments of the Odyssey Homer's epic poem
about the hero Odysseus is 20-year
journey home after the Trojan War occurs
near the end of the poem Odysseus has
finally made it back to his home country
and he sits in disguise face to face
with his wife who's been waiting for his
return for nearly twenty years when she
asks the stranger who sits in front of
her to declare who he is
Odysseus pretends that he traveled with
her husband as a crew member and a
soldier he describes his own travels as
if he merely witnessed them and then he
makes several oaths swearing that her
husband will return in this moment he
chooses not to disclose that he is in
fact her long-lost husband but in one
striking speech while he's still
concealing his identity
Odysseus declares dry your tears and
hear me because I speak the truth
without concealment
he'll tale moment in the story of
Odysseus he's a master at intertwining
truth and deception homer even opens the
Odyssey with the line Oh goddess of
inspiration sing to me of wily Odysseus
that master of schemes today will look
at a disease as the flawed Greek hero
celebrated in the Odyssey and in other
material from the so called epic cycle
long lost poems related to the Trojan
War will pay particular attention to the
ways that Odysseus is scheming and his
lies lead to heroic triumphs and how
they also nearly kill him
Odysseus who is also known by the Latin
version of his name Ulysses was a
legendary king of ancient Ithaca an
island located in the Ionian Sea there's
some disagreement about his parentage
according to legend Odysseus's mother
was anti clear and Homer tells us that
his father was Laertes a Greek King a
different tradition however states that
Odysseus was the son of Sisyphus an
ancient king of Corinth who was said to
have been punished by the gods by being
forced eternally to roll a heavy boulder
up a hillside only to have it roll right
back down the hill forcing him to begin
the task all over again the rest of
Odysseus is life however is described
fairly consistently Odysseus was married
to Penelope and together they had a much
beloved son Telemachus Odysseus is
hailed as a hero in the Trojan War and
like the Trojan War there are debates as
to whether or not he actually existed
those who believe that the Trojan War
actually happened usually dated around
1200 BCE
so if Odysseus really lived it was over
3,000 years ago
The Odyssey begins when most of
Odysseus's adventures already behind him
homer drops us into the story when
Odysseus is near the end of his journey
after being held captive by the
beautiful nymph Calypso now Calypso has
kept him on an island as her lover for
nearly seven years but as the epic opens
Odysseus is about to be offered the
chance to leave
despite being nearly shipwrecked by a
storm sent by Poseidon for reasons we'll
talk about later he makes it barely
alive to another Island known as ficha
his hosts offer him a ship to Ithaca but
first they asked him to describe his
past journeys before he leaves and we
get to eavesdrop on these stories this
is how we learn about his adventures in
addition as the Odyssey begins Odysseus
has grown son Telemachus is searching
for news of his father men who served
with though dis-ease in the Trojan War
describe his bravery and his cunning and
they encouraged Telemachus not to give
up on his long-lost father between the
stories told to Telemachus and
Odysseus's own reminiscences we learn
about Odysseus's past
there aren't many stories about
Odysseus's childhood he first attracts
attention as a young man when he Woo's
beautiful Helen of Troy when the Spartan
King Menelaus finally wins Helen as his
wife
Odysseus wisely encourages the king to
obtain pledges from her former suitors
that they will defend his marriage
rights to battle if necessary it turns
out though that when Menelaus tries to
collect on these promises Odysseus
himself bulks when Helen is abducted by
Paras
Menelaus sends a representative Pella
Metis to Odysseus as homestead in order
to recruit him for war against Troy but
Odysseus has married Penelope by this
time and he has an infant son Telemachus
so he's reluctant to leave his family
in addition Odysseus is aware of an
Oracle prophesying that if he leaves for
war he will not return home for 20 years
this prophecy sets the stage for the
rest of the epoch Odysseus learns that
palamidi is on his way and in a
characteristic act of cunning Odysseus
decides to pretend that he's gone crazy
in effect he disguises himself as a
madman he goes to extreme lengths first
sowing his fields with salt which
renders the fields completely useless
for farming
then he harnesses a goat and an ox to
his plow these animals are mismatched
and so they pull the plow haphazardly
while Odysseus pretends to urge them on
but if these acts are supposed to
convince pala Metis that Odysseus has
lost his senses palamedes does not fall
for the trick in a kind of dare pala
Metis picks up Telemachus Odysseus's
newborn child pala Metis places the baby
in the field directly in the path of
Odysseus's plow blade in effect he
challenges Odysseus to prove his lunacy
by driving a plow straight through his
own son's body
Odysseus steps away from the plow and
despair acknowledging that he has not in
fact gone mad an Apollo Doris's version
of the story
Odysseus bemoans his fate as he sets off
for war and he never forgives pala Metis
for forcing him to go
the stories continue with tales of
Odysseus's service in the Trojan War
once Odysseus joins Menelaus as army he
is 100% committed and his cunning serves
him well his first act is to recruit the
great warrior Achilles to the cause now
the Prophet Calchas had declared that
Troy would never be taken without
Achilles help
however Achilles mother had been told
that her son would either die young as a
hero at Troy or live a long unremarkable
life at home now this choice may sound
familiar
remember that Heracles was offered a
similar choice and in characteristic
fashion he chose the harder path but
Achilles mother is not anxious to send
her son into danger just as Odysseus
tried to trick palamidi
in order to avoid battle Achilles mother
tries to trick Odysseus in order to save
her son from going to Troy
Achilles mother disguises the warrior as
a young woman and she sends him to live
with King like Oh Metis hoping that he
will blend in with the women in the
Kings household but Odysseus remember is
the master schemer and he suspects a
trick he sets up a trap in order to
trick Achilles into revealing himself
Odysseus offers gifts to the daughters
of like Oh Metis household gifts such as
gold and jewelry and fine dresses but he
also includes weapons in this collection
of gifts and Achilles betrays himself by
focusing on the weapons rather than on
the traditional women's gifts then
Odysseus unexpectedly sounds of battle
horn and Achilles instinctively grabs a
weapon in a shield girding himself for
battle and in doing this he reveals
himself this makes it possible for
Odysseus to recruit Achilles who was
absolutely essential for victory against
Troy
Odysseus is also responsible for the
famous deception known as the Trojan
horse now we'll go over the details of
this story in a later lecture when we
talked about the Aeneid but in short
after 10 years of warfare at the siege
of Troy the Greeks pretend to surrender
and they depart they leave behind a huge
wooden horse as a kind of peace offering
despite warnings the Trojans ultimately
are convinced to bring the horse inside
the city gates as a kind of a war trophy
the next night 50 Greek warriors
including Odysseus emerge from the
wooden horse and they attack and with
this move the Greeks finally conquer
Troy and the long war ends
both of these stories showcase
Odysseus's chief qualities his
cleverness and his bravery throughout
the war these qualities serve him well
but when the long war is over he turns
his face toward Ithaca and at this point
Odysseus his scheming becomes a problem
for him he and his men begin to suffer
as a direct result of his cunning and
his pride it's worth lingering over this
point for a moment the very skills that
make men like Odysseus effective
military leaders often create problems
when they're off the battlefield
it's as if heroes aren't really
comfortable when they're not here owing
imagine General George Patton without
his command
Odysseus displays cleverness even when
it's not called for and what he
considers acts of bravery come across
sometimes as misplaced arrogance as a
result the prophecy is fulfilled and it
takes ten more years for Odysseus to
return to his home and his family
in the homeric material Odysseus's
stories focus on the years after the war
and his efforts to return home to
penelope and to his son
these stories are perhaps the best known
stories about Odysseus because they're
the most entertaining
they include monsters gods and goddesses
and the underworld
early on Odysseus and his soldiers are
captured by the Cyclops Polyphemus a
one-eyed giant Polyphemus is cast in the
role of a barbarian
he's lawless he lives apart from society
and he ignores traditional Greek rules
of hospitality which would oblige him to
shelter Odysseus and his men as guests
instead the Cyclops begins to eat
Odysseus's men two by two at this point
Odysseus must rely on his cunning to
maneuver and escape
Odysseus makes Polyphemus drunk with
wine and while the Cyclops is asleep
Odysseus and his men ignite a large
wooden stake and then they drive it into
Polyphemus as I blinding him this point
the men are still trapped because the
Cyclops blocks the entrance to his cave
he only lets his sheep in and out of the
entrance to graze and he runs his hand
over the back of the sheep as they come
and go
just to make sure that none of Odysseus
men ride away on them Odysseus and his
men escaped by clinging to the underside
of the Cyclops a sheep as they move in
and out of the cave cleverly eluding
detection Odysseus and his men escaped
because of Odysseus is clever thinking
but at the last moment
Odysseus is pride gets the better of him
as he begins to sail away from the
Cyclops Island he can't resist bragging
a bit so he shouts out his name
declaring if any man should ask you who
blinded you shamed you so say that
Odysseus Raider of cities he gouged out
your eye
Laertes son who makes his home in Ithaca
well the Cyclops then tells his own
father Poseidon what Odysseus has done
Poseidon is already irritated with
Odysseus in part because they were on
opposite sides in the Trojan War after
Odysseus blinds Poseidon's son the
Cyclops
Poseidon himself becomes enraged he
works systematically to make it very
difficult for Odysseus to return home
throwing obstacle after obstacle in his
path Homer writes all the gods had pity
Lord
Odysseus all but Poseidon raging cold
and rough against the brave King until
he came ashore at last on his own land
at this point Odysseus adventures become
increasingly discouraging at one point
Odysseus and his remaining soldiers come
right within view of Ithaca exhausted
Odysseus collapses into sleep on the
ship his men who have been told to keep
a special sack tightly closed until they
have arrived safely home greedily open
it thinking it must contain gold or
treasure
in fact it contains all the ill winds
that would have kept the ship from
returning to Ithaca these winds are
released when they open the sack and
Odysseus and his men find themselves
driven away to the island of the
sorceress Circe
Odysseus journeys also become
increasingly dark eventually like
Heracles Odysseus and his men travel to
the underworld the spirit or shade of
Odysseus's dead mother tells him that
his wife is being pursued by suitors who
claimed that Odysseus is dead and
they're competing to take over his wife
and his home
Odysseus resumes his journey home
avoiding the dangerous sirens the
mermaid-like creatures who take on the
forms of beautiful women and sing so
enchantingly that sailors literally
steer their ships into the rocky shores
of their Island rather than turning away
from the siren song
after escaping the sirens Odysseus and
his men also navigate successfully
between the monster Scylla and the
Whirlpool Charybdis but only at great
cost
Odysseus continued to lose his soldiers
one after another and he's ultimately
trapped absolutely alone on an island as
Calypso's captive
it's here that we meet him at the
beginning of Homer's epic at this point
Odysseus is not the confident war hero
now he's the lonely wanderer who wants
nothing more than return home and to his
family once homer has brought us up to
speed
the story begins to move forward but at
this point with a hero who is very much
changed after being released from
Calypso's Island and nearly drowned by
poseidon storms Odysseus is brought
naked and loan to the fee a ssin sure
when a dist Odysseus finishes telling
this long story to his VA Shin hosts
they deliver him finally to Ithaca but
he doesn't return in triumph as a
precautionary move
Athena disguises the mighty king and war
hero Odysseus as a poor beggar so that
no one will recognize him
after decades away we find Odysseus
walking the noisy streets of Ithaca
determining how best to reclaim his
family and his throne he meets his wife
without her recognizing him now Penelope
loves her husband and she's a loyal wife
so throughout the years of Odysseus as
absence Penelope has remained faithful
but she and her son had been invaded by
Prince's desiring to take over Odysseus
his kingdom and to take his wife and
Penelope can no longer withstand the
pressure to remarry
some scholars argue that Penelope notes
the resemblance between the bigger she
encounters and her long-lost husband and
so she devises a plan to draw him out
other scholars argue that Penelope
simply tries to devise a strategy to
delay choosing the second husband
without realizing that she's actually
setting up the perfect opportunity for
Odysseus to reveal himself in any case
Penelope tells the disguised Odysseus
that she can no longer put off her
suitors she must choose someone to marry
in order to select her future husband
she has decided to hold a competition
among her suitors the suitors will be
required to string Odysseus's bow and
shoot an arrow through 12 axe heads
whoever can fulfill this task will have
her hand in marriage
Odysseus of course immediately decides
to participate in the contest
while awaiting this event Odysseus is
recognized by Penelope's maid Urich Leah
Penelope asks Yorick Leah to bathe his
feet and to anoint them with oil Yorick
Leah who was Odysseus is nurse when he
was just a child recognizes a scar on
Odysseus leg that he got when he was
hunting as a young man and in a poignant
moment the woman recognizes Odysseus at
once and she reaches out her hand to
touch his face but Odysseus stop sir and
he silences her that she will not give
away his identity prematurely
Odysseus wears her to secrecy and he
waits for the competition
the day of the contest suitor after
suitor tries to string the bow but fails
and finally Odysseus steps up
he strings the bow and he sends the
arrow flying through all 12 ax heads and
then with the help of his son Telemachus
and the goddess Athena and others he
attacks and he kills all the suitors who
have presumed to take over his household
then Odysseus's Odysseus orders the
servant women who slept and plotted with
Penelope suitors to clean up their
corpses and then he actually hangs these
women and finally he reveals himself
directly to Penelope who still can't
believe that her long-lost husband has
finally returned when he asks for a
place to lie down she tests him just one
last time by ordering a servant in his
presence to move Odysseus his bed out of
their wedding chamber now
Odysseus declares this can't be done
because he actually built the bed
decades earlier and he built it around a
living olive tree at this
Penelope accepts that this man truly is
her husband and Odysseus is restored to
his home and to his family
why had the stories of Odysseus stood
the test of time at a basic level it's
obvious
Odysseus adventures are incredibly
entertaining after all Odysseus battles
with gods and monsters and he always
emerges victorious he is admired by men
he is desired by women and throughout he
stays faithful to his people and to his
family he's the ultimate leading man and
adventurer hero this is the stuff of
Bartok entertainment remember that most
of these stories began as oral
traditions so they were filled with
imaginative elements to keep the
listeners attention
for the ancient Greeks the story of
Odysseus was a little bit history and a
little bit hero worship Odysseus is
story even if it's not literally true
puts Greek history on a cosmic stage it
suggested that the gods cared enough
about the Greeks to intervene in their
lives from time to time now note that
Odysseus was not half God like Heracles
whatever his parentage he was immortal
like the rest of us therefore as a hero
Odysseus set a standard against which
all other men were meant to measure
themselves most heroes weren't
worshipped like the gods they didn't
receive sacrifices or have festival days
established in their honor but the gods
existed in another realm
no one could aspire to be a god heroes
like Odysseus on the other hand set a
high but an attainable bar Odysseus was
George Washington General Patton and
Douglas MacArthur all rolled into one
at another level the Odysseus stories
give us real insight into distinctive
ancient Greek mythic themes the theme of
cunning and scheming runs throughout
Greek mythology it was a valued trait in
Greek citizens in addition as classicist
john and bel notes Greek myth is
preoccupied with identity this is part
of what distinguishes it from mere
folktale
the Odysseus myths explore identity in
distinctive ways
unlike other Greek heroes Odysseus
changes his name and he conceals or
alters his identity several times
throughout his adventures at one point
he even calls himself a [ __ ] in effect
calling himself a liar
he even takes on the name nobody in his
exchange with the Cyclops Polyphemus and
in a cruel twist of fate the one time he
actually proclaims his true identity as
he and his men are escaping from
Polyphemus ittan dangers them all Bell
argues that at this moment the folktale
about a man escaping a monster actually
becomes a true myth the mythic hero even
at the risk of endangering his own life
and his men's lives must assert his
identity
this story becomes loaded with
additional meaning and it takes on
significance beyond the events it
describes throughout Odysseus's entire
life his identity is alternately
concealed and revealed concealed and
revealed this finally comes to an end
when he returns home to reclaim his
household and his own family
more than any other Greek mythic figure
Odysseus searches for a place at a time
where he can be publicly at peace with
his full true identity and this personal
search may be the key element of the
Odyssey that distinguishes it from other
Greek myths more than any other
character Odysseus disguises himself and
takes on different personalities one by
one the sailors under his command his
travelling companions fall away
ultimately leaving him alone and exposed
he finally returns home
disguised as a person at the very bottom
of the social order
he's been humbled stripped of
companionship and stripped of any
meaningful identity only at that moment
can he come home and resume his rightful
identity it's somewhat of a paradox the
grand epic is ultimately a deeply
personal story of one man losing himself
and then finding himself again
at a deeper level I read Odysseus's
journeys as metaphors for experiences in
everyday life true most of us are not
tempted by sirens but the sirens
represent temptations that we do face
temptations that initially seem
attractive and that encourage us to turn
away from a long difficult path the
story of Odysseus is escaped from the
sirens reminds us so that's nothing new
to be tempted with short-term pleasure
and the seduction will be short-lived
similarly when Odysseus and his men
traveled to the western edge of the
world or to speak with the dead these
journeys are metaphors for the times
that we feel far from home separated
from comforting friends and family
in the Odyssey Odysseus finds out in the
underworld that his mother has committed
suicide and that his wife is being
besieged by suitors who want to take
over his throne and his family at that
moment he's filled with a new sense of
urgency about returning home Joseph
Campbell the famous myth scholar called
these belly of the whale experiences
like the biblical figure of Jonah who
was swallowed by a whale and seemingly
at the end of his life
Odysseus travels as far away from home
as humanly possible literally to the
underworld
to the land of the dead only in this
dark room like and tomb-like place do
Jonah and Odysseus come to terms with
their true circumstances
Campbell argues that we all have these
moments when we recognize that the old
world we used to cling to is gone and
that it's time to move forward toward a
new world whatever that might be
it's important to note that when
Odysseus was born his maternal
grandfather gave him his name which
means the son of pain he declared that
this was a name the boy would earn in
full I think we're supposed to hear this
as a warning that Odysseus will
experience great pain in his life he
certainly experiences physical pain but
in many ways this is the least
significant in fact the only mark of
physical injury that stays with him is
the scar on his leg that he got as a
young man while hunting this is a scar
of innocence of youth and it reconnects
him to his family when his old nursemaid
recognizes him because of that scar
the implication is that Odysseus's
physical challenges in the Trojan War
and in the long journey home are
fleeting they're secondary to the truly
lasting changes that he undergoes
I think though that we can also think of
Odysseus as a son of pain in the sense
that Odysseus as a man his character
after the 20-year journey was forged out
of pain Odysseus is true pain is
reflected in his stories of the journey
home stories in which his own pride and
his attempt at shrewdness cost all of
his men their lives and delay his own
return physical pain is nothing to a
hero but the pain of being faced with
the frailties of your own character
being faced with the losses that others
have experienced because of your
failings
that's the hero's pain
and Odysseus's character as a mature man
is born out of this pain I think Homer
hints at this by not telling Odysseus's
story directly or in chronological order
but by inviting his listeners to
eavesdrop on a mature man's reflections
on the past 20 years of his life by most
estimates Odysseus would have been about
25 when he left for Troy a young virile
powerful man in the prime of his manhood
but 20 years of war and wandering mature
this man and we meet him in his middle
age physically a bit past his prime but
much wiser
in the Odyssey homer structures the
story so that he tells the tale of the
telling of a tale Odysseus is retelling
of his own adventures his reminiscing is
as significant as the contents of the
stories themselves it's a story of
personal transformation and Joseph
Campbell argues that it is in particular
the story of a hero's transformation
now Campbell's approach to myth has its
problems but I do find it helpful in
understanding the Odyssey the hero's
journey or as Campbell refers to it the
monomyth includes three parts first the
hero separates from his known world
either voluntarily or by force then he
encounters a world previously unknown to
him and he undergoes a kind of
initiation where he's introduced to
unimaginative I it and he subsequently
returns to his former world as a wiser
man
in Campbell's thinking Odysseus was the
quintessential hero forced against his
will to take on a dreaded task separated
from loved ones for decades matured and
humbled by his experiences and his own
flaws but then reborn near the end of
his journey
Odysseus washes up on the shore of an
island completely alone and completely
naked like a newborn over the past
twenty years he's been stripped of his
friends his allies and his dignity he
experiences a kind of Weber or at least
a rite of passage as he's changed from
the proud warrior into a thoughtful man
Odysseus has tasted both the pleasures
of Calypso's Island and the darkness of
Hades and he reenters life in Ithaca a
new man
the figure of Odysseus has inspired many
other stories throughout the ages
Odysseus appears in ancient Greek plays
by Aeschylus Sophocles and Euripides and
he's a key figure in Virgil's Aeneid in
modern times he's the focus of
Tennyson's poem Ulysses in which the
protagonist leaves his son to rule the
Ithacan people as he sets sail on one
final journey beyond the sunset he also
appears in the form of Leopold Bloom in
James Joyce's famous novel Ulysses
making a journey comparable to the epic
20-year journey but all in a single day
the Odyssey is also said to have
inspired the Coen Brothers film o
brother where art thou what is it about
Odysseus story that draws us back to it
again and again fundamentally I think
the answer is that Odysseus is both the
mythological Superman and everyman
initially Odysseus comes across as the
hero of a fantasy adventure his
adventures are not the adventures that
most of us face in the real world he
matches wits with terrifying creatures
such as the Cyclops and the six-headed
monster skill and he triumphs he's the
original MacGyver determining how best
to use whatever is at hand to fashion
his escape he's a man's man in a woman's
fantasy he battles armies and dangerous
creatures like an action hero
consistently defeating his enemies and
constantly fending off the advances of
beautiful women
but as his story unfolds he becomes more
like every man every reader can relate
to his lifelong commitment to family and
home to his struggle between desire and
duty and to his acknowledgement that his
strengths are occasionally also the
cause of his undoing Odysseus's journey
is our journey and ultimately his goal
is always to return home in this he
embodies what we like to think our basic
human impulses and he's rewarded much as
we all would like to be he returns home
from his labors welcomed into the loving
arms of his family scarred but a little
wiser